hey guys I'm Ryan wri and I'm Alana Cole
and I'm Erica Flynn just met Erica and
Alana Alana has a YouTube channel Erica
goes on YouTube channel and now she's on
this channel we're going to watch a
video today from km Peele a lot of
people have been saying I should check
out videos from them I've actually seen
some of ke have you guys seen kmele no
no they have a sketch comedy show
they're so [__] funny put the [__]
on the chain wax H only guy in the room
who gets the joke right now I don't get
the joke put the [__] on the chain
wax no I don't get it well it's from ke
and Peele it's an inside joke that you
guys aren't included on oh fine Welcome
to the Real rejects ladies Where I Leave
people left
out been trying to reach out to you all
day are we on for
tonight
jeez what you can't catch me you can't
catch me I'm Lance Mo touchdown [__]
what
pause I like a
sweatshirt we pizzas
yeah shoot Keegan's been texting
me sorry dude missed your
texts I assumed we'd meet at the
bar whatever I don't
care
sorry dude missed your texts I assumed
we'd meet at the bar whatever I don't
care whatever I don't
care the [__]
is that happens to me all the time do
you even want to hang out do you even
want to hang out oh let's consider
it like I said whatever like I said
whatever is he supposed to be like the
girl gu Jesus you are [__]
priceless you're the one who's [__]
priceless
this he's the girl he's the guy this is
like me analyzing my text messages yeah
this is literally girls analyzing their
text messes you want to go right now
H guess I could do that
okay okay let's go
said you know what you know what you
want to really do this now Keegan you
nut you're not putting me out [__] yeah
let's do it oh you [__]
[__] oh no Erica this is us this is
literally our life it's going be a
[__] street
[Applause]
fight no
buddy like I said first round's mine a
beer and a gimlet oh my God my partner
right what's
that uh I I I got you a baseball bat
with nails in
it for my post-apocalyptic Jackie
Robinson costume how did you
know wait that's literally girls
analyzing their text messages that's
literally me did you not I get like that
too actually I'm sensitive I miss read
text messages all the time and mistake
them for angry tones I also do the other
side too where I'm like cool and then
they're like pissed at me I'm like why
no you guys get into this situation well
actually yes I call her every day and
she doesn't answer I'm like hello [__]
hello oh yeah and then she texts me and
she says if you don't call can you say
she just asked if she can say [__] on
this channel I saw SE CRA she texts me
and she's like all right I called you if
you don't call me back you're a [__] so
I think she's pretty straight up I think
we know where we stand text message wise
at least I don't know if I want a text
relationship with you I love key andele
man they have some of the funniest
sketches and I love the acting behind
them too I like that he kicked his feet
in the yeah it's those little things
that they do anyone could have high
energy and commit to it but they have a
certain level of high energy that will
actually like be just believable enough
so that way you can actually laugh at it
and not so real words it's UNC they have
like a really good balance of that that
was really they work really good
together I know I I feel like that was
literally so relatable so relatable cuz
like that's guys text girls and guys
were him just like oh yeah and the girl
freaking out and you say things too that
are very passive like oh you're like
[__] priceless for the other person
could easily mistake it but you're like
really angry the one thing I wish they
touched on was like punctuation marks
and LOL and stuff sometimes someone be
nice
ifem emojis that could have been
something they cover too yeah like the
text messages could have just popped
into the bottom the bottom of the screen
that would been nice that's no that
would have been a that
element I think so thanks so Lana mhm
putting my
input stop I have literally s oh no are
you trying to make a dirty joke did it
work kind of input inut input my input
you thought of it before I did that was
a great video thank you guys for telling
me to watch a KMEL video because they
really brighten up my day this has been
coming up with every video with Alana in
it she is a quarter black so this is
like you relate I really related to you
really related you you must have yeah
and she isn't to black people but she
loves them I'm also related to them are
you mhm I'm not black my cousins are
black your cousins are they married and
cousins or blood well they're my blood
but they're like their dad we like black
people I'm trying to just establish that
people and every other
race sure you said it in my other video
just putting that out there as well put
out putting it putting it all out there
I like to throw it out there if if I had
a back throw out sorry I have a
problem wait how does throw it out there
I don't know it could be anything I feel
like if you hear someone's tone you're
going to assume it's a sex joke yeah
make anything dirty we like friends
Remember Have you ever seen that episode
Jo Joey goes you can make anything dirty
they're like Joey how do you make
anything dirty and he goes watch he's
like Grandma's chicken salad
salad yep do you watch Friends yes cool
you watch something thank you Alana
sorry your friends here so it's become
making fun of Alana I know it's
literally been making fun of Alana it
always is that's what's happened when we
up anyway guys if you're new to the
channel you can subscribe to the real
rejects Alana has a YouTube channel
Channel too she's she's seriously she's
a really good YouTuber so subscribe to
her Channel Erica has us as friends yep
which is good for her she has YouTube
Friends y it's healthy for you and as
far as shout outs go all caught up so
facebook.com/ the real reject shout outs
shout it
out